do you have a sense of where
a hypothesis of where
is the cocoon that it might have come
from
no because uh okay so first of all
you know the solar system the outermost
edge of the solar system is called the
oort cloud
it's a cloud of icy rocks
um of different sizes
that were left over from the formation
of the solar system
yes and it's thought to be roughly
a ball or a sphere and it's halfway the
extent of it is roughly halfway to the
nearest
star okay so you can imagine
each planetary system basically
touching uh the oort clouds of those
stars that are near us are touching each
other
space is full of these billiard balls
that are
very densely packed yes and what that
means is
any object that you see irrespective of
whether it came from the local standard
so we said that this object is special
because it came from a local standard of
rest but even
if it didn't you would never be able to
trace where it came from because
all these old clouds overlap so if you
take
some direction in the sky you will cross
as many stars as you have in that
direction like
there is no way to tell which old cloud
it came from so yes i didn't realize how
densely packed everything was uh
yeah uh from the perspective of our
cloud that's really interesting so
yeah it could be it could be nearby it
could be very far away yeah
we have no clue
you